und zur gleichen zeit schloss meseberg
nördlich von berlin größer könnte der
kontrast zu den ruinen von mario pohl
nicht sein aber auch dort bei der ersten
kabinettsklausur der ampel regierung
ging es um krieg gegen die ukraine und
die beiden damen die bundeskanzler olaf
scholz sieht durch den barockgarten
führt sind die ministerpräsidentinnen
von schweden und finnland die angesichts
der gefahr durch putin noch in diesem
monat einen antrag auf mitgliedschaft in
der nato stellen wollen scholz hat ihnen
dafür die volle unterstützung
deutschlands zugesichert
und
jetzt der nächste kontrast vom
schlossgarten wieder in die ukraine
während olaf scholz immer noch nicht
nach kiew gekommen ist reiste
oppositionsführer friedrich merz in der
nacht dorthin nicht mit einer
sondermaschine und bka schutz sondern im
schlafwagen
friedrich merz und waldimir selensky
heute in kiew in der ukraine
ich kann nur sagen jeden respekt große
anerkennung und ich denke wir sind in
deutschland auch weiter verpflichtet
diesem land zur hälfte der cdu chef ist
seit heute in der ukraine um sich einen
persönlichen eindruck zu verschaffen mit
dem nachtzug ging es quer durch das
kriegs gebeutelte land eine nacht im
schlafwagen
auf dem weg nach kiew wir haben eine
interessante reise wenn
alles sicher alles gut und die
ukrainischen behörden äußerst kooperativ
sehr angenehme menschen es ist schön in
diesem sonst während merz noch in
romantik über die ukraine steckt kämpfen
die soldaten in der ost ukraine um ihr
leben täglich sterben hier menschen nach
einer sicheren reise kommt der cdu
chefin
in dem tier war vor ort wo die russen
ein massaker an der ukrainischen
bevölkerung angerichtet haben der
deutsche oppositionsführer ist emotional
aufgewühlt von seiner reise voller
trauer über die zahlreichen opfer dies
hier gegeben hat aber auch gleichzeitig
voller bewunderung über das was die
armee was die ukrainischen soldatinnen
und soldaten hier geleistet haben denn
an dieser stelle hier ist der vormarsch
der russischen armee gestoppt worden oft
erfurt mit friedrich merz ist nun ein
weiterer deutscher politiker in die
ukraine gereist vielleicht erhöht er so
den druck auf bundeskanzlerin abseits
denn der ist der einzige der wirklich
etwas in der ukraine bewirken kann
und wir schalten in die ukraine zu
unserem reporter paul ronzheimer direkt
an der frontlinie im donbass japan im
schlafwagen nach tier iv und die reise
war nicht ganz unumstritten man hat
friedrich merz auch unterstellt er wolle
einfach nur den bundeskanzler vorführen
aber wenn wir die bilder jetzt gesehen
haben wenn wir sehen wie fröhlich märz
dort vor ort sieht was tatsächlich
passiert ist und entsprechend ergriffen
ist dann würde ich sagen ist das echt
ja diesen vorwurf habe ich ohnehin als
zu billig empfunden denn nur weil der
bundeskanzlerin nicht her fährt kann das
ja nicht bedeuten dass andere deutsche
politiker auch nicht hierher fahren ganz
im gegenteil ich fand es von anfang an
wichtig dass friedrich merz dieses
zeichen setzt und man muss eines sagen
thomas ihm ist ein echter coup gelungen
fast eine stunde hat er offenbar mit
präsident ski dem ukrainischen
präsidenten sprechen können das ist so
wie mir meine ukrainischen fällen
berichten so passiert dass er andere
jacke getroffen hat den stabschef den
ängsten mann an der seite von präsident
ski und dann kamen sie lenski dazu also
bis zuletzt war offen ob dieser termin
tatsächlich passiert er war nicht im
terminkalender des präsidenten der
präsident ist dann sozusagen dazu
gestoßen aber das ist natürlich das bild
was am meisten transportiert friedrich
merz trifft den mann der so sehnlichst
darauf gewartet hat dass olaf scholz zu
ihm fährt oder scholz vielleicht
zusammen mit emanuel marco und dieser
olaf scholz dem gestern noch hat
ausrichten lassen nein ich werde nicht
kommen und das liegt daran dass kiew
meinen bundespräsidenten und ehemaligen
parteifreund frank walter steinmeier
ausgeladen hat also das noch mal
erneuert hat ich kann es nicht sagen um
was aber vielleicht hat das den
präsidenten besonders motiviert zu sagen
nein jetzt treffe ich den
oppositionsführer wenn der scholz wieder
wir ausrichten lässt dass er nicht
planen zu kommen ja und das obwohl er ja
eigentlich nichts im gepäck hat als
oppositionsführer gleichwohl aber gerade
jetzt auch im bundestag eben ja auch
zustimmen muss als größte
oppositionspartei wenn es beispielsweise
um die lieferung schwerer waffen geht so
wie wir hören
paul und du wirst es besser wissen weil
du die klitschkos sehr gut kennst wenn
er sich auch mit witali klitschko holen
aussprechen möglicherweise auch noch
eine pressekonferenz geben
so ist es das geplante treffen mit
vitali und wladimir klitschko oder immer
noch an seiner seite wald in kiew ist
jetzt für diese stunden geplant das
ganze hatte sich verzögert weil eben das
treffen dann mit dem präsidenten
passierte mit dem man kaum noch
gerechnet hatte und jetzt geht es dann
weiter mit diesen stunden zum gespräch
mit vitali und wladimir klitschko danach
soll es eine pressekonferenz geben
aber man muss sagen thomas das ist schon
ein klares zeichen richtung meseberg da
wo olaf scholz takt und dort wusste man
bis zuletzt auch nicht ob friedrich merz
diesen termin bekommt er hat sich mit
dem kanzleramt nicht abgestimmt über die
details der reise man hat da keine
rücksprache gehalten sondern tatsächlich
das ist ausschließlich friedrich merz
und die cdu gewesen die diesen trip auch
geplant und organisiert haben kleiner
wermutstropfen muss man sagen friedrich
merz ist dann doch ein bisschen vom pech
verfolgt denn ausgerechnet fast in der
gleichen minute als das foto von ihm mit
lothar bisky dem präsidenten öffentlich
wurde wurde eben auch öffentlich dass
der cdu-generalsekretär aufgrund eines
skandals zurücktreten musste und das
könnte ihm jetzt wieder so ein bisschen
ja die aufmerksamkeit nehmen naja hab
doch er hatte persönliche eindrücke
gewonnen das ist natürlich noch
wichtiger paul der letzte frage ganz
kurz noch da du dort an der front bis
wie ist die situation bei dir
wir waren heute unterwegs bei lima in
einer region in donets und es sind immer
die gleichen erschütternden bilder die
man dort sieht thomas zum einen die
einschläge heftige artillerie geräusche
und dann der versuch der armee
zivilisten zu evakuieren also ähnlich
wie philipp das rund um mario pohl
berichtet hat in weitaus dramatischeren
umfang aber dort ist es aus und man
versucht die leute aus diesen dörfern
den kleinen städten herauszuholen weil
die russische armee doch zumindest
langsam vorankommt und der beschuss so
heftig ist dass die leute schwer
traumatisiert sind einige verletzt
manche tod und alle kaum wissen wo sie
hin soll
euro vielen dank paul